all right this is the fourth and final
in a series of videos about how to
tackle the DBQ
or document-based question on the AP
u.s. History exam now we started out by
reading all of the documents that are
provided in the exam from which we are
to write an essay that analyzes the
major changes and continuities in the
social and economic experiences of
African Americans migrating from the
rural South to urban areas in the north
in the period 1910 to 1930 so as we
analyze these primary documents we kind
of identified three major themes that we
want to talk about and that was cultural
differences between the south and the
north differences in the type of labor
between the south and the north and
differences in patterns of segregation
in the south and the north and from
these themes we came up with a thesis
which was more or less that the more
things change the more things stay the
same so even though African Americans
moved to a whole new city a whole new
environment a whole new system of labor
they couldn't escape persistent racism
which had similar effects on their lives
in the north as it did in the south so
now we're at the writing the essay part
and while obviously I can't sit here and
write a whole essay on this screen I do
want to outline things for you give you
a general sense of what you could talk
about we're so for the DBQ we're going
to do a standard five paragraph essay
which means introduction with a thesis
statement paragraph one paragraph 2
paragraph 3 these will all be the body
paragraphs where we'll give our evidence
in support of our thesis and then a
conclusion which wraps up what we've
said before and really drives home our
point now in this essay to get full
credit you should expect to use either
all or all but one of the primary
documents that
provided and that means you need to
reference them all although you don't
necessarily have to go into detail about
every single one of them and what I want
to caution you against doing is just
talking about each piece of evidence one
after another without putting them into
a larger framework of ideas so don't
just say oh well you know first there
was a folk saying about the effect of
the boll weevil and sharecropping
on black southerners lives and then some
of them asked for help moving north they
wrote to the Chicago Defender because
you don't want to just let this evidence
lead you along what you want to do
instead is say that you have read these
pieces of evidence you have analyzed
them and now you're going to synthesize
them into an argument of your own now
this is where the themes come in handy
because we've taken the time to see
what's going on in all of these
documents and kind of bubble up to the
surface what are the real important
issues that people are talking about and
as we thought about changes and
continuities in those things the thesis
that we came up with was more or less
that even though the form of each of
these things changed the form of the
culture the form of the labor the form
of the segregation the underlying
problem of racism kind of remained so
this thesis actually gives us a really
neat structure for the rest of the essay
because we've said the forum's changed
but the underlying problems stayed the
same so for each of these body
paragraphs we'll talk first about the
change in form but then we'll talk about
the underlying problems that stay the
same
alright are you ready to take a stab at
writing this so let's kind of ease into
things with our introduction so I think
a good thing for us to do might be to
set the scene a little bit and we talked
about some of the historical events that
were going on at this time period so you
might say that sharecropping had really
been an economic loss for
african-americans and so they were
feeling the pressure both from the
system of sharecropping where 50% of
what they got was sent back to
landowners and also from the boll weevil
which had killed off a considerable
amount of the crop so they just weren't
doing okay
you could also mention that in 1890s
the Supreme Court case Plessy versus
Ferguson had made separate but equal
accommodations legal for blacks and for
whites which basically put racism as
part of the law so if there had been any
hope remaining that the Civil War and
reconstruction were going to result in a
society in the South that was not based
on racial discrimination was kind of
destroyed with Plessy versus Ferguson at
least for the time being and then lastly
you might say that
World War one as the United States
mobilized for the war led to many new
factory jobs in the north which gave
african-americans in the south an
opportunity to leave okay so at the end
of your first paragraph in the
introduction this is the time to bring
out your thesis so our thesis is even
though African Americans who moved from
the south to the north in the period
1910 to 1930 experienced tremendous
changes in the culture surrounding them
the work that they did and their living
patterns they still suffered from many
of the same problems that they had
suffered from in the south due to the
pervasive influence of racism in a way
what you're saying here is that racism
was a national problem in the United
States it didn't change from north to
south so even though the form that
racism took might be different in South
Carolina and Chicago there was
no real qualitative difference in its
impact on the lives of African Americans
okay this is where we break out our
themes so our first theme was about
cultural differences so remember our
structure first we're going to talk
about the things that were different and
then we're going to talk about the
things that stayed the same so one thing
that was different would be that if
sharecroppers moved to the city they're
moving from a rural to an urban
environment where many african-americans
in the south had worked as sharecroppers
and lived in a farming situation now
they were headed to the heart of the
city where they might be surrounded by
other african-americans I bring up the
map from document 7 here and they were
also worried about what it would be like
to take a job in the city somewhere that
was completely far away from home this
would be a part where you might consider
talking about the newspaper letter in
document 2 where a man writes to the
Chicago Defender asking for help because
he's afraid he might get hoodwinked so
what are some of the things that stayed
the same well I think we can definitely
say that some of their fears were
justified about the move to this city
because many people found that life
there was just as hard as it was in the
south and we see that in this document
about the Cotton Belt blues we might
even say on kind of a larger cultural
level that white people in the north
were no more kind to them than white
people in the south
and here you might consider bringing up
document number 6 the one about the race
riot in Chicago okay that's a paragraph
about cultural differences how about
labor differences all right what in our
second paragraph we're going to talk
about how even though african-americans
moved to a completely different type of
Labor from sharecropping to factory work
they still faced pervasive racism in the
factory system that led to White's
rioting and all
Oh segregated facilities even bathroom
facilities in these workplaces so the
thing that changes is the type of labor
and here you might want to bring up the
first document where you're talking
about sharecropping alright so what kind
of work they were doing was different
but the same kind of problems that they
faced in the workplace were quite
similar so they faced segregation in the
workplace and they faced stereotypes
about the kind of work they did and
whether or not they were good workers
and here you might bring up the third
article where the efficiency expert
talks about how it's important to
separate white and black workers that
you don't have any kind of racial
friction in your office and you might
also talk about the sixth article where
they say that many people believe that
african-american workers were used as
scabs in strikes so that's a kind of way
of separating the races that's saying
that white workers and unions might be
undermined by black laborers willing to
work for less alright lastly we're
talking about the experience of
segregation now we've already mentioned
this transition from a rural to an urban
environment but you might also talk
about how living patterns change so in
the South African Americans and whites
usually lived in similar places in the
same town in the same parts of town more
or less but the way that they used space
was slightly different so for example
African Americans were often expected to
use the servants entrance sit either at
the back of a movie theater or maybe not
even go into the same places as a white
person but in Chicago there's an entire
african-american neighborhood and for
this you definitely want to bring up
document 7 which shows where F
and Americans were living in Chicago and
the thing that stays the same is really
the system of segregation itself
northern segregation looks different but
it's still segregation so you might talk
about I mean this is still segregation
is one thing you you can say and you can
also say that there's kind of a implicit
promise of violence if African Americans
step out of line in the system of
segregation and here you might talk
about document number four which is this
kind of smearing newspaper article from
a white newspaper in Mississippi saying
oh well in Mississippi we have lynching
in the north they have explosions you
know their point was oh well isn't
lynching better but for the purposes of
your essay what you can really say is
what's the difference they're both forms
of death for getting out of line in a
system of racism so there's nothing
that's really all that different there
anyway and now we're at the conclusion
so generally I would advise you against
bringing up any new information in a
conclusion because you want your reader
to come away saying oh yeah that was
right not wait a minute the author
didn't talk about that in the essay at
all why are they mentioning it in the
conclusion so I would advise you to just
kind of restate what you've been talking
about throughout the essay saying that
even though there's this vast
transformation in the culture the living
situations the work of African Americans
who are moving from the south to the
north the substantive problem of racism
stayed the same all right well that's it
for the DBQ taking the time to do your
due diligence in understanding these
documents and coming up with an idea and
a structure and even an outline will
really pay off in the long run because
it will help you to write an essay that
is really strong and really clear